hallo deutsche mein Name ist Hannes Lot
und ich bin Deutschlands erster AFD
Bürgermeister wir haben gefordert die
kitaitapätze kostenlos zu machen das
klappt leider nicht dafür werden wir die
kiterplätze 60% teurer machen ich hätte
mir gar nicht vorstellen können dass das
was kostet meine Frau passt ja auch
umsonst auf die Kinder auf dass das so
teuer ist das ist teurer als ein
Bordellbesuch und macht weniger Spaß wir
wollten auch die Feuerwehrhäuser
sanieren das geht jetzt nicht wegen der
Pleite aber ich habe privat einen
Feuerwehrmann gekauft für die Kita von
Playmobil was soll ich denn noch machen
ja ist ja bekanntermaßen nicht alles
deswegen gibt's jetzt von mir ein
Gutscheinheft für alle die hier im Ort
wohnen selbst gemacht ja hier z.B für
eine Umarmung ja oder einmal Kinder
abholen beim
Sportverein oder auch ein kostenloses
Jahr Praktikum bei mir gerne wir haben
gesagt wir wollen den Preis der Kita
ändern das ist uns gelungen es ist ja
nicht wichtig ob das Auto vorwärts oder
rückwärts fährt wichtig ist dass Gas
gibt und ich stehe mit beiden Beinen auf
dem Gaspedal